welcome back to a very special edition
of Beth Rigby interviews from Liverpool
[Music]
good evening after a long break we are
back and we have a new prime minister
but today we're not in London we're
bringing you a very special show from
Liverpool just over there the labor
party have just wrapped up their annual
conference but Liverpool is far more
than just a labor Heartland it's
vibrancy it's people it's football make
this a great city to live in but just a
few weeks ago Liverpool was rocked by
the murder of nine-year-old Olivia Pratt
corball shot and killed in her own home
her killer has still not been found how
can this be tonight we hear from a
former gang member and one of the stars
of Liverpool narcos
but first Liverpool Football Club is the
Beating Heart of this city it's also one
of the most successful clubs ever in the
English Premier League so who better to
catch up with while I was here than
Liverpool Captain Jordan Henderson
Jordan Henson thanks so much for joining
us it's a real pleasure genuinely to
meet you thank you um and behind us
we've got these kids
playing football you're sponsoring this
program to get more kids to play
football 30 000 kids involved are you
concerned that kids aren't getting
enough exercise or that their parents
can't pay for exercise classes I think
in the world we're living at the minute
you know cost of living is becoming an
issue of course
um so to put on free sessions for kids
kids aged 5 to 11 I think is really
really important you know just to get
them outside running about playing
meeting new friends being in a team
environment and things that I think
football can give so much especially
when you're young I mean the smiles that
it puts on the kids faces and I think
it's um I think it's really special with
with what this this scheme is yeah and
just in terms of kids I was looking into
it in terms of kids and exercise and
childhood obesity is on the rise recent
statistics showed that overweight or
obesity uh in year six so by the time
kids are 10 to 11 it's 34 of children
that that's quite a lot isn't it that
sounds a lot yeah
um so yeah again when I was a kid you
know he didn't have so many computer
games or social media on the phone
things that I think that's obviously
evolved as time's gone on and a lot more
kids like to stay in the house playing
computer games and stuff which has been
which has been the case for a long time
but I think it just increases but I
think stuff like this is amazing you
know to get kids out get them playing
get them enjoying it
um and football is such a big part of
this country and a big part of Liverpool
though big part of Liverpool here
definitely a big part of society here so
um I think it's important just to come
and make sure the kids are enjoying it
and
you are quite unusual in the football
Community there's in the sort of amount
of charity work and work for the
community that you do I'm sort of
thinking Marcus rashford obviously is
really known for the free school Mills
program so he's dealing with kids that
aren't getting enough food and he
launched that campaign it made him a
hero national hero but it also made him
a Target and I was wondering with the
work you do you've got this massive
platform and you can do this and promote
healthy living for kids and football but
it's not risk-free for you sometimes
is there sometimes a bit of Jeopardy for
you in going beyond the job going beyond
the football pitch if you like to do
charity work or or to promote causes or
do you just think
I'm a privileged guy
I've got this great platform and I
should just do it well that's exactly
really I'm not really bothered about
what people think I'm in a position a
privileged position where I can help
people and if I'm passionate about
something
then I'll do it you know things like
this for kids you mentioned Marcus who's
done amazing work and off the pitch as
well I think that's really important I
think
people look at footballers as if we're
not we're not human beings but you know
when we were kids and the struggles that
we seen for us to be able to give back
is yeah give me great pride to be able
to come here and it's an honor to be
able to try and give back to the
community not only at Liverpool but
where I'm from in Sunderland as well
yeah you so you sort of feel you have a
responsibility to do it yeah definitely
definitely I think I wouldn't be I
wouldn't be where I am today with
without the the work ethic and the
things that were instilled in as a kid
from Sunderland so to be able to give
back there is is really important to me
but also Liverpool as well I know how
big football and how passionate they are
about football here and they've given
awful lot to me and to the team and so
again it's it's a no-brainer for me to
be able to try and help kids and people
in this area and your dad was a
policeman wasn't he and uh so did he
sort of have this sort of sense of
public service and you think you that's
the values you grew up with
uh maybe maybe I haven't really thought
about that too much I just think it's
the right thing to do ultimately
um if I'm in a position where I can help
other people
um then I don't see a reason why I
shouldn't just because people might see
one or two things and for me it's about
just doing what I think is right and
trying to help as much as possible and
you um
now you're very true you're clearly
clearly in shape and you're still at the
top of your game in terms of football
but is this is the charity work you're
doing do you see it at some point as a
bridge into a post Jordan Henson
football world like this might be the
sort of stuff you might do in the future
you absolutely nowhere near that point
yeah I think charity work is something
that I've always tried to do behind the
scenes and always want to be involved in
and I hope that will continue right
while I'm playing and obviously when I
finish I'll always continue to give back
because I feel the responsibility and I
feel like I need to really and it's
important for me to do that so yeah
definitely carry on I'll just carry on
as long as possible but I think everyone
watching this sort of Liverpool football
fans and England football fans will want
to you to be carrying on on the pitch
for a little while yeah so let's talk a
little bit if we can about your football
career you're the Liverpool Captain yeah
let's just all pause there take that in
uh you're an England player you you've
won the Champion League the Premier
League title the UEFA super cup what is
the dream for you like what you do next
is it a wild can't win I mean the Euro
finals must have hurt like what's the
next goal for you professionally it
never stops really
um you'd think that because you win
trophies that that's your dream and you
sort of wonder where you're going to go
from there but actually
it makes you more hungry for more to be
honest
um so every competition that I'm
involved in whether it's Liverpool or
England I want to win
um and I give absolutely everything to
try me best to help the team achieve
that but you you have been at this for a
long time you were in the Sunderland
Academy when you were just eight years
old like a little tot you made your
first team debut a decade later you
signed for Liverpool in 2011 you became
Captain did you think when you were like
the eight-year-old you did you imagine
that you could do this that this was
where your destiny would be or did it
just sort of I think it obviously
evolves over time but I've always I've
always dreamed about being a footballer
I've always dreamed about
representing the country I've always
dreamed about winning Premier League
champions league so I've always dreamed
about them things but you know I'm sure
there's plenty of kids that dream about
that at a very young age and I've been
very fortunate and lucky enough to work
with a lot of good people have good
people around us and um and have the
attitude and the desire that want to go
and Achieve me dreams and yeah luckily
I've I've been able to do that and
hopefully I can continue doing that but
it wasn't
I mean the thing is it wasn't always
with that adversity was it I mean no
one's career ever is is it I mean in
your younger days you were really tested
in the expectation of Liverpool when you
first joining you're a pretty young man
at that point weren't you and I think
after a year of signing you they nearly
sold you or they wanted to sell you to
Fulham that must have been was like
really difficult for you was that like a
at the time at the time it was a
difficult moment in my career I spoke
about it a few times so at the time you
know a young player coming into
Liverpool it was it was a difficult
period but looking back
it was an important period for me
developing as a as a person and made a
stronger and and actually I wouldn't
change I wouldn't change that path at
all I felt as though that time really
did make it was a lot stronger mentally
um and it's helped us do with a lot more
going forward but resilience do you
think it made you more empathetic as
well like I've noticed that you are
people's mental health issues or being
different and feeling excluded either
thinking about
um that tweet you did after that
non-binary fan posted about feeling
scared about going into games they were
wearing makeup and you were really kind
about that do you think
that that is linked back to some of the
things you struggled with when you were
younger
I think yeah I think in the stuff that
I've I've done in the past of our mental
health and things like that that
definitely is something that
um when I look back
um I experience difficult times and I
think when you're playing at the level
that that I am you're gonna go through
tough times
um and the pressure is high but that's
the world we're living and it's about
how you deal with that the processes and
I was again I was lucky enough to have
really good people around us
um and like and again with the with the
tweet and things that either for me it's
about doing the right things and
um and trying to help people and make
people feel comfortable because at the
end of the day football is for everyone
yeah and you should feel comfortable
wanting to go to watch a football game
or one at the Congo a coaching session
whatever it may be everybody should feel
comfortable doing that but it's
important because if people like you
don't point that out
then a lot of people feel excluded but
it can put a Target on your back
sometimes but you're prepared to do that
yeah because again it's the right thing
to do in my mind in order to try and
help people because I don't think it's
right that people are uncomfortable
going to a football game at all
um so if I can help in any small way
then I feel a responsibility that that I
need to do that and I won't dwell on
this but just in terms of the pressure
which I cannot begin to imagine what the
pressure must be playing Top Flight not
just National but International Football
you must have been very pleased about
the draw against England against Germany
that was exactly what they needed are
yeah I was a little bit disappointed
because I felt we were so close to
winning the game in the end but I think
that was a snapshot
in terms of how the mentality of the
team I think they've had a lot of
criticism
um over the last couple of camps and
performances and results that were we
haven't had
um or what that we've had um hasn't been
great and we know that as a team and and
you've got to go through tough times
um and I think I've experienced that
over my career you know these tough
times can actually meet you go one way
or the other yeah in um and I felt as
though last night was was a big moment
for us as a team in terms of the
mentality I think two nil down against
Germany you know it can go it can go
um it can go one or two years and I felt
it was all were responded really well
come back into the game and and probably
should have won it in the end you're a
leader you're a leader on the pitch
you're a leader in your community and
with klopp and Southgate you also work
with two exceptional leaders what do you
try to emulate uh from both of them like
what's the thing that you you may stood
more about them or the thing that you
try and harness for yourself in your own
game or in how you live even I think
you're right I think leadership is
something that has got to be natural but
you can also improve and develop that as
well and I've been so lucky again to
work with so many big personalities big
leaders players managers all of my
career which has helped me and Jurgen
and Gareth probably complete completely
opposite people I would see a totally
different but have different qualities
in what way just
um
I just think they're just totally
different are they yeah just totally
different in terms of the way the work
and the way they do things
um
and for me personally obviously I've got
a lot to thank them for yeah um but
especially Jurgen since he came here and
what he's done for me is a player
um and as a captain really and as a
person you know I think he's helped us
develop so much on and off the field
um and he's been a huge part in need
development over the last five years or
so why can you give me example how
they're different though just like I
just think that they're just in terms of
leadership I think leadership can come
in so many different forms
someone who will Who you'll follow
um and he's very much uh
charismatic yeah charismatic and you
believe everything he says he's very
um
speaks very well in front of the the
group and knows exactly what he wants
and we all follow
um whereas the whereas on the other hand
I feel as though Gareth
um has a different way about him and
will involve probably players a lot more
and have get their opinions and see how
they want to go about different things
and it has a different way of of working
and the both work and so it's it's
fortunate enough for me to be able to
see because you can learn from different
styles yeah that is really interesting I
wanted to ask you about the pandemic
because you set up uh the money for the
NHS during covid the players together
campaign it raised 4 million at launch I
don't know how much it ended up raising
um
it was an incredible thing to do
the then Health secretary Matt Hancock
I'm sure you saw it said around that
time that footballers should take a pay
cut and play their part right and you
did you I don't want to get really into
politics here but
um Darry Neville said yesterday that's
what inspired him to get into politics
like did you think that's a bit of a
cheap shot from Hancock or were you just
like I'm doing my thing don't care what
you say
yeah it was it was a cheap shot I'm sure
I don't know why what the reason was
whether or not he wanted to deflect away
from the pressure that he was under or
whatever but again for us it wasn't
we're already in in the in the process
of doing stuff
um and yeah we felt a responsibility as
a group of players across the league
that were in a privileged position again
we can really help and um and we all got
together all the captains got together
and raised a lot of money there wasn't a
figured out Lies by you yeah well us I
would say we definitely gonna of course
I was involved in that but
um yeah I raised a lot of money we
didn't put the figures out there because
again
it was four million at large presumably
it was a lot more than that at the end
but you don't want to say yeah we didn't
want to put a figure we didn't want to
tell me now now it's passed because we
know we never did and we never we never
wanted that to happen because you didn't
want that we didn't we thought it was
never it would never be enough really
and we didn't want people to know what
it was because I think no matter how
much careers there wasn't so much about
that it was about everybody coming
together to support people who really
needed at that time and the money went a
really good causes and we just felt as
though it wasn't right to put out the
figure do you sort of feel like you you
sort of ramped up the NHS fund do you
feel like that in terms of I need a lot
of charity work that the cost of living
crisis is something that you feel that
is an area that you're going to want to
kind of lean into or do more work with
in the next couple of years if I if I
can help definitely you know if this
area is that I can that I feel as though
I can help with then I'll do it and I've
got a obviously nor the information and
be really passionate about it but if
that's something that I need to help
with I know I know LFC Foundation do a
lot of work in the
um in Liverpool with with cost of living
and families and things like that which
is really good
um Olivia you put her name on your shirt
when you
played a match
against Bournemouth how do you think
what's happened to Olivia and her
family's affected Liverpool
I think it affected everybody in the
city really I think you know I can
remember my wife's telling as the story
I didn't hear it she taught us and it
really
um struck a chord really you know same
age as my eldest daughter
and I couldn't imagine the pain that the
family must be going through
um
so yeah I'm so difficult which is which
is why I felt I needed to to put a
message on the game because it was so
close to the game yeah
um it was a little thing I know but yeah
everybody was hurting and um
it was a really tough time for the
family and like I said I couldn't
imagine that the pain that they're going
through and just in terms of what's
Happening Now your dad obviously was a
policeman the police can't find who did
it
yeah again that must be so difficult for
the family
um but in the end I hope they can and
and I hope that they do
um because I'm sure that's what the
family won but it's such a sad thing to
happen such a young age taking far too
early
um
and um yeah it's it was a it was a it
was a did straight record when that when
I heard the news I'm sure that um your
what you did also
comforted a lot of people who were
really struggling with it at the time so
I'm sure that I know you said it was
just a small gesture but
it probably made a difference to people
so anyway thank you so much I really
enjoyed talking to you thank you so much
really good thank you
well we're here in Liverpool and I'm
joined by John Burton he's a former gang
boss and now he spends his time helping
prisoners find work John thanks so much
for being on the show that's great nice
to meet you and thanks for having me now
obviously I want to talk to you about
um your life of crime what you do now
and also some of the issues about crime
in Liverpool at the moment you
understand that well better than most
but what I want to do is you have such a
fascinating
quite astonishing story what was it like
being a young boy in Liverpool in the
80s I loved it it was great
um I used I was born in Brazen in
Liverpool Town Center off Foxhall Road
moved on to an estate probably seven
eight hundred hours and these were all
people who had come from tenements
Apartments flat stuff like that and all
moved on to this estate so it was
basically fines and loads of new mates
and loads of new families that moved on
and that's what we begged he was
probably God he was probably about
hundreds of us same age all along and
around together at the same time how on
Earth did you go
from this kid
having a lot of fun loving life as you
said how did you go from that to at the
age of 11 selling drugs on the streets
what was going on I think when I was
about 11 I think a group of me and a
group of me mates started smoking weed
and then from there we started buying
bits of weeds and selling it to just get
our own smoke and stuff like that and
then as you're growing up a little bit
people take notice and then I ended up
sort of working with old aladstone when
I was about 13 14 and obviously I was to
people say I got groomed and exploited
actually I didn't I wanted to do it you
were named
as The Mastermind of a one million
conspiracy to sell one million pound
conspiracy spelled drugs across the city
yeah and it was then 211.
I got caught in 2000.
you like literally like are you have you
become the gang Master at this point not
the gang masterboard because I was
probably top of the tree
and top of the tree means it was me that
was sauce and the cigarettes or the
drugs it was me that was putting it all
together and it was me that was sort of
working with my friends so you're
running people now yeah yeah
there are so many horror stories of
gangs uh depicted in TV shows on Films
documentaries like the one you featured
in which was Liverpool narcos
is it really like that was it a life of
violence as well
when you're in a when you're in a drug
World it can be yeah because what you've
got to understand in a drug world
it's about getting your drugs into the
country it's about shipping them drugs
around to different people and then it
becomes a problem when someone doesn't
pay bills and stuff like that on it were
you violent I presumably in them days
you have to be you went into jail before
2012 when you got the big Century 2011
yeah so you so you came so you've been
in you came out and then you got the big
sentence right so I went away in early
2000s got out in 2005. carried on yeah
come out and carried on I got caught in
2011. I got a nine and a half year
sentence and then another five years on
top of that right and then so you now
you now you're facing 14 years in jail
yeah is that the moment you thought I've
got to check no oh no no I want to go
back in and want them watching I'll come
in and I ended up going to a category a
uni which is a circum high security unit
is that so you're one of the highest
securities
it is but that's where people think but
when you're the prisoner you're going
into just it's normal people like you've
been with some some are saving 20 30 40
years and you're in with murderers and
really violent people right yeah I
suppose you were a really violent person
you come onto that category when when
you serve and drugs and if the police
want to make um
I want to make you pay for what you've
done then they'll put you in like a
Qatar unit you basically come out what
changed for you
um I was sent down to the Isle of shepi
in Kent and I've had to do my last few
years there
seeing what I put my children through my
family through also traveling down there
17 18 hours on a round trip to come and
see me for an hour
I just thought you know what it's time
to sort of get a grip now my family
travels everywhere how long have you
been in prison
where you thought okay I can't do this
three years so you did three years
you're still kind of
being a bit nefarious really yeah I was
bad from the Northwest so I couldn't go
to any prisons in the Northwest so it
was shipped out of the North because you
were literally organizing well they said
they had too much influence on Prison
officers
prisons so you moved here and then you
have this Epiphany thing I can't do this
to my family
so your Epiphany was you couldn't put
your family through it you came out you
couldn't come home so that must have
been really hard but then you set up
this social Enterprise
what does it do so it helps people in
prison people coming out of prison and
it helps them to rehabilitate and what I
I'm like a thunder disruptor I don't
like putting courses on that'll take
four weeks when you just want to draw
down funds and when we can put someone
on a week two week course or a
three-week course depending on what type
of job it is and just let's get them
into work
if we keep people outside for four five
six weeks on Universal Credit not
getting much of an income
the opportunities are going to come in
front of them and then before you know
it click of a finger you're back in
prison and you've been awarded the
Robert Corbett award during a sermon in
the House of Commons during the ceremony
lady Val Corbett said in this year alone
182 people on their program
have achieved industry qualifications
with the 98 success rate that must feel
to start right the wrongs of the past
for you a bit it does it does and like
someone said to me how do you feel about
getting your rewards I went look I'm
honored to receive an awards I said but
my Awards is seeing people rehabilitate
and get a life after prison that's my
rewards watching people going into I
just wanted to now talk to you about
Olivia What's Happening Here in
Liverpool on the 22nd of August Olivia
Pratt corball was killed after a gunman
fired shots into her home about 10 pm
chased by another man this incident has
not just shot Liverpool it's reverberate
around the country and
everyone
parents I mean just everyone like for a
little girl to be killed in that manner
is is beyond imaginable
um
how has it impacted the community here
and how do you feel about it as someone
that was involved in this sort of crime
and gun crime this it's like now I speak
to a lot of people about the Ripple
effects and think before you do
so when you go and do something and you
don't think about doing it then these
are the Ripple effects that happen along
the way and unfortunately there was a
young girl who was killed and it's it's
not on
you know that that poor girl was you
know she was behind a door but that guy
run into their house he had no right to
run into their house and her mom and her
mom got shot through the hands and the
same bullet went and killed Olivia can
you imagine how it's it's awful it is
it's really bad and you know and I know
probably a lot of people in the criminal
worlds are not even happy about it
happening
but it's the Ripple effects of not
thinking about stuff there's a 200 000
reward
being offered for information leading to
the conviction of those responsible it's
the biggest reward in Crime Stoppers
history
how can they not find this person and
how can people in the criminal
organizations in Liverpool not hand this
person over well I don't understand I
don't understand that myself but you
know it's it's who it was or how it was
done no one's really going to know but
the police must have
um evidence and stuff because they're
arresting people for an assistant
offenders and stuff like that so they
must have names that they're sort of
putting it down let me put it to another
way are you surprised that the killer
has still not been found yeah
Jones when when he got killed a long
time ago he was names flying rounds
everywhere and they eventually got the
killer in the end
is the person being protected by I 100
couldn't I couldn't I couldn't tell you
that but you know something something's
not right but I'm pretty sure look the
biggest gang in this country of the
police
and I'm pretty sure they will cut the
kill 100 because they're putting
everything into it to find out who it is
how he's done it and what it is and it
won't be it won't be long before the
killers found John thank you thanks for
telling me you're welcome your story
that's the work you do with prisoners I
mean it's
it's a great thing that you do now and
thanks for coming on the show not a
problem we've got to help rehabilitate
people so become better people in life
that's the way I see you thanks thank
you
well thank you to our guests and thank
you to you too for watching if you want
a bit more you can check out our Beth
Rigby interviews podcast where you'll
get the biggest guests we've had on and
also Molly Malone my producer and I will
talk about the politics of this week you
can find it wherever you get your
podcast and also why don't you send us
an email Beth
rigbypodcast.uk always like to hear from
you thanks for watching and we'll see
you next week
foreign
[Music]